welcome to the podcast everybody
how are you
you guys are all over the world i i'm in
the city that we all live in you're
you're elsewhere
can you tell us where you are
i'm in new york city
ah new york city new york city at a
fancy old hotel
oh [ __ ] the big apple what are you
sipping there
i'm sitting here go go go do whatever
you got to do i'll talk to charlie [ __ ]
this guy right
i mean let's get of let's just [ __ ] this
guy he wants to get up i know he can
still hear us uh he's got the house he's
got the earbuds in [ __ ] damn it all
right he's outsmarted us again oh that's
a nice place you're staying in hey man
it's not too bad kate caitlin is very
upset she noticed the angle that i use
she's very upset with it she thinks that
people give a flying [ __ ] about what is
in the background and i i don't care
but i do appreciate that glenn made it
look nice
uh
no this is just what it looked like i i
keep it nice
i keep it nice you know what i mean i
was the first spot where you know you
got a little natural sun shining on your
face uh
you know without a hideous background
this is really the only spot i had where
i could get both those things it's a
little bit of a weird thing but look
we're both showing you know kitchen
stuff i guess
rob
um yes yeah for the listener um i'm sure
this is absolutely fascinating um i
already get in there they're talking
about the kitchen stuff you can see in
the background of the shots which i
cannot see because i'm just listening
but get out of here they're gonna keep
describing it get over here
well all the creeps can see that um
glenn looks like he's wearing some sort
of a beanie um real fascinating look i'm
into it um i'm into it and then for the
listeners it's not gonna mean much to
you but it's worth maybe checking out on
on the youtube or the video podcast
because it's it's it's an interesting
look a little bit of a prison cap i know
what it's about though
i know it's about i don't know if you
want to like talk about what it's about
or if that's so i i i ran this i
actually ran this by uh some people just
in case it in case it came up and i
figured it would just because it's like
yeah it's time to avoid
you can't hide it but you can't hide i
don't know why i chose to wear this
particular hat it's just it was kind of
a last minute thing i was like oh [ __ ] i
need a hat
um yeah so i am doing a i'm in toronto
because i'm shooting a movie and my
character is um is bald on top
uh not you know completely bald just you
know male pattern baldness bald on top
and uh so um yeah i mean i'll show it
doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't look that great right now
because uh we did the hair and makeup
test on monday so it's had a little
chance to to kind of grow back in but uh
it's glorious man
it is glorious yeah it's growing a
little bit
the pictures you sent were astounding
it's amazing i mean
any listener right now needs to become a
creep very quickly it's worth becoming a
creep just to watch glenn glenn looks as
creepy as possible he's now one of
he's a creep if you are a seeing creep
um
glenn has shaved his head hair but left
the sides although the sides are very
tight as well
it's pretty tight yeah it it changes uh
over the course of the film um it starts
kind of longer like this and then by the
end it's a little more jason statham you
know what i mean it's a little more like
down
man down real tight well you know maybe
not not as short as this is right now
but it looks it's so good
it's how are you feeling about it
potential ability to come back you think
it's you know or
this look
no no i mean like the hair go back
or
have you damaged you did the razor hit
all the plugs and
jack those i mean
it's not that it did the thought crossed
my mind for sure um you know but i
thought well that's just stupid i mean i
shave my face all the time and the hair
always comes back like what's you know i
mean they're just their hair follicles
how delicate could they be
and yet i feel like i have heard stories
and i don't know if you guys have you
ever had anybody was like yeah i shaved
my head and it never came back like i
feel like i heard some people say that
but i feel like danny said that to me
once
yeah yeah right right he's like
yeah i took it all off once and then
that was it but i don't know i could be
making that up now are you using one of
our one are you utilizing our sponsors
because we have a sponsor who who could
maybe take care of that head
wrong
yeah hey come on
hey
a joke's in for the listeners the creeps
and they made a sexual reference
speaking of sex speaking of sexual
references and speaking of sex offenders
uh which is the look that that glenn
does have going on right now and it's
not just the baldness it's the it's the
whole i mean rob no it isn't i think you
would have more like a parisian safe
cracker or something with that oh yeah
thank you for putting on that's i prefer
that i prefer that spin
like you're going to tiptoe into that
apartment and you might have a croissant
and uh then you're going to crash i'm
going to guess that anybody who's a
parisian safe cracker is also a sex
offender
you know just be just throwing that out
there that is so of you are so offensive
today like why can't you be
i've just run into too many french
people who are [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
sorry i don't know
we're doing our best have you ever met a
country full of more [ __ ] maybe the
u.s okay fine all right fine we've got a
lot of [ __ ] running around here too
but man
well it is an interesting move to be
like i'm mad that like i'm mad that you
don't know my language and i'm also mad
that you're trying to learn it
yeah you know what i mean like you're
mad at it you give it a shot
yeah yeah they're just mad they're just
angry you're good they're just they're
everybody i don't know what they're so
angry about they live in a beautiful
country i mean
they hate that we saved them from well
no i didn't my grandfather did our
you're still hanging around your father
did
i think so they're i think they're upset
about them just getting their [ __ ]
asses kicked and the u.s had to come in
and save the sorry and so did the
russians we we saved you guys
anyway i'm just i'm now i'm upset about
the french yeah no you're okay with this
french i mean rob i am very popular in
france i can't go anywhere near this
it's uh oh maybe maybe that's what it is
i'm angry that they have no idea who i
am
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know
[ __ ] everybody yeah
i i had an old i had an old roommate who
was french and he and i loved him he's
lovely and his family was lovely so it's
not all the french but you know what i'm
saying it's a vibe it's the way i think
they're it's the way i think
yeah and they're they're aware i think i
think the friend i think the french are
aware that there is a certain
you know number of them that don't uh
you know and they probably feel
misrepresented by uh the rude ones you
know because i'm sure there's a quite a
few
uh friendly french people but they do
have a reputation for for being a bit a
bit sort of like
snooty
right little
little sort of uh dismissive snooty uh
like you know it's this whole thing of
like you know you you try to stumble
through a couple french phrases because
you're trying to order french fries the
right way in the country and they're
just like
like i love it what they always do they
they come up to the table they
immediately start speaking french
because they don't know where you're
from although they could probably tell
so maybe they don't but
but that's fair you're that's fair
you're in their nation and they're going
to speak french to you okay great
no but that's the whole thing once they
if they know once they know you are you
you're an english-speaking person they
stopped speaking french entirely
because they're like we're not even
going to play this [ __ ] game i don't
have time for this [ __ ] and you know
what they're not totally wrong
that's got to be [ __ ] annoying after
a while to watch just you're like i got
i got 10 tables i got 10 [ __ ] tables
i got to listen to this guy stumble
through his shitty french every time
no
it's not it's not going to work for me
but even that would be okay
i have so many cigarettes
i have 15 more cigarettes to smoke in
the next hour
[Laughter]
okay
um well so this episode's not going to
travel well over there i
know well uh i uh so check it out i'm
just gonna say france and if we're
playing big in france we'll cut all that
oh that's not a bad idea all right okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah so meg you'll check
the numbers and then decide to cut that
cut that cut that or not
there is no mag
meg is very close to france right now
meg is somewhere in the heathrow airport
oh do you think she's just like tearing
tearing through the airport like all
frantic and sweaty and [ __ ] like trying
to get to her computer yes
yes she's very upset that she's that
she's missing this even though we've
made it very very clear that it's it's
okay to be in heathrow airport and not
be able to get a great wi-fi signal
it's a whole thing you know you go
somewhere else and the phone takes a
minute to be like how do i get a how do
i get the interweb
right what is this what's what's the
system what is this you know what maybe
if she's in heathrow she's there's
there's definitely some french people
around maybe she could go up and talk to
a few of them and just see if they're
nice see if the first
if if their first instinct is to say
hello um you're a fellow human it's a
pleasure to meet you um
or would they just say something sort of
look at you with disdain because you're
american you know who's really nice
you know who's really nice french
canadians can idiot yeah canadians well
canadians and canadians yeah
just just an absolutely lovely lovely i
was in a store the other day and there
were so many uh so much gratitude being
thrown around you know from all the
customers and everyone who worked it was
a whole smile like a a guy you know i
bought some wine and uh and a guy and
the guy said uh you know thanks thanks
very much for thank me for coming in
thank you very much for coming in i said
well i appreciate you and he goes i
appreciate you
like that was the exchange it was like
well i was like thanks man i appreciate
you and he goes and i appreciate you
and he meant it he meant it it wasn't
snarky like i couldn't even deliver it
real i i like it it even came off snarky
when i did it doesn't mean i appreciate
you
like but it was very it was very he
meant it you know what i mean like so i
actually um i don't i don't know
when when i was uh this was back in 2004
i was visiting uh a friend um
uh who we all know morena background she
was doing a pilot
sorry she was doing a tv show in
vancouver
and uh i went up there to visit her and
we were hanging out and we were driving
somewhere
and you know this was like
four years after i oh no sorry three
years after i'd moved from new york city
to los angeles
and you know both both places you know
can can bring out the uh the cynic or
sort of the uh misanthropic side of of
anyone um but uh anyway there was we
were sitting in the car and there was we
were waiting at a red light and there
was a crosswalk and a guy walked in
front of the car and he walked in front
of the car and he's just kind of walking
like this and he looks over at us
sitting in the car and he's like
and he waves like that and then he turns
and keeps walking
miranda and i are both like
the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this guy up to i don't know
what is he going oh [ __ ] what does he
want what is this guy what does he want
to move
what what is that [ __ ] what is that [ __ ]
what does he want from us you know what
i mean and then he just kept walking and
both of us looked at each other and were
like oh [ __ ] we're [ __ ] like that
guy was just being nice he was just
being nice that's it he saw us and he
was like gave us a wave and was like
you know just wanted us to have a good
day he was he was floating on a [ __ ]
cloud
and he wanted us to feel the same way
you know i don't know i see i think new
york gets a bad rap because i think
people assume that new yorkers are
[ __ ] and i never found that at all i
i feel like new york was an incredibly
friendly city as compared relative to
other other cities and countries i've
always found that to be the case i think
it would be used
to be more of a note yeah brash like
more of a no-nonsense like all right
hurry up do your order
my uncle had a really funny story about
his first time visiting new york city
and he was like this like
tennessee mountain man and he's uh
walking down the street there's a cop
standing on the corner and he walks up
to the cop and he goes like uh morning
officer and the cop goes yeah very funny
keep it moving
very funny
yeah yeah yeah hilarious guy oh good
morning oh yeah i guess it is a good
morning
yes
yeah well i think what you're referring
to robin you're not totally wrong i i
actually feel the same way about new
yorkers i think you're i think you're
right i mean look there's [ __ ]
everywhere but i think in general i
think you're right but um the difference
is and i think that that you know coming
from philly you also
find this find this refreshing coming
from the south
you know where everyone is just like
overly polite um i actually found
the directness the candor and the
brashness of a lot of new yorkers very
refreshing i was just kind of like oh
great you're not like trying to couch
this in a bunch of like flowery [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's how i feel don't don't
don't give me the fake sweet i'll take
i'll take an [ __ ] over someone who's
fake sweet absolutely absolutely
then then go to the midwest because
that's for goddamn sure that's legit too
you go to anywhere in wisconsin for
example you walk around and i that is a
genuine
genuine kindness and compassion that
i've that no it's just a kindness i'm
here for that's great
yeah illinois wisconsin like the
the middle part of this country you walk
around and they mean it yeah when they
say so how are you
how are you i mean you know they they
they they mean it that's not like a you
know i'm from the south i have to put on
airs and you know look i sound like i'm
coming down on all southerners i am a
southerner i just i just found that
there there's a certain
number of people in the south who have a
tendency to kind of
do this performative sort of greeting
every time you walk in the room and like
how y'all doing it's so great to see
y'all
and you're just like
why why is it that great it's not that
great to see me i know it isn't i know
it's not that great to see me so don't
don't [ __ ] throw out that oh my gosh
how long has it been you're not really
wondering how long it's been
you don't [ __ ] care how long it's
been who cares it's just it's [ __ ]
it's performative i don't like it well i
i have not spent as much time in the
south as you have but i can say that
when i do when i do go down there have
traveled to say louisiana or mississippi
or texas i appreciate it because i'm not
getting on i'm not getting it on the
regular so it is nice to have people
just come up and
and whether it's fake or not i have no
idea because i'm only there for a week
at a time and i'm i'm enjoying the nice
the niceties but i could see that maybe
over time you start to sniff out who's
who you start to see through it i i
think you find that most people wherever
you go
wherever in the world their resting
state is fairly nice
and accommodating not in france not in
france and then what happened what
happened there i don't know i don't know
not again not to suggest that how many
people there's millions and millions and
millions of people that live in france
they're not all
[ __ ] but they're resting like you
have to get past the artifice and then
you find oh wow
what are you what are you so afraid of
what are you so afraid of over there
guys uh oh you think it's fear nothing
because there is no point to life and
exchange that we are having and he's
meaningless
meaningless and i feel nothing about
malays
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're still supported by athletic greens
uh and their green drink powder
ag-1
a combination of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics and glenn how do
you say it adaptogens adaptogens
i mean it's great i i take it uh you
know first thing in the morning so it
gets absorbed on an empty stomach i'm
getting all those nutrients like right
into my system it tastes excellent and i
feel like it doesn't taste too healthy
which is good i don't want it to taste
too healthy
what about the smell i love i love the
way it smells it smells delicious think
about the smells you [ __ ] think of the
smells that can confirm it smells just
fine to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
sunny okay that's important
athleticgreens.com
sunny that's how meg gets her money
again megan doesn't get paid megan
doesn't get paid all right unless you go
to athletic greens.com
sunny okay take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
[Music]
well all right so we took care of the
french should we talk about the yeah
should we yes well i have to say i'm i'm
excited to talk about the episode but i
just i miss you guys i haven't seen you
in a while and i like talking to you
just about your life and what's going on
so
oh okay well hey listen pal but i'm
happy to transition i mean look i wish
you're here in new york city man ton of
fun this town and sure so we got we got
toronto we got la we got new york and
we've got london i mean we're are we
well you guys are the jet setters i'm
just sort of sitting in my the same
place yeah well i think we should talk
about the episode uh do you guys
remember where the impetus what the
impetus for this episode was no
do you
no
i don't at all around the time it was a
time where there there was a new law
that was out that was that was making
people
that you you had to register as as a sex
offender i will say this feels like to
me like one of the episodes where we
just had a funny concept like hey what
if dennis looked a lot like a guy who
was a registered sex offender i feel
like that is could have just been like a
card on the wall
like somebody looks like a sex offender
or something well i mean you know we
used to uh
i mean i used to and i think you did too
rob and maybe you too charlie but like
used to like kind of
just skim through philadelphia
newspapers to see what was going on in
the city you know see if there was
something
specific to philadelphia that we wanted
to deal with and there was a new sex
offender law that had been passed about
you know how they have to register
um
might have been one of those headlines
that that caught our eye and we went
you know oh okay that's that's kind of
an interesting you know thing and then
to have
you know dennis uh look like this guy i
don't know where that came from but uh
i'll tell you what
i was very excited when we were breaking
that episode that the thought of like
actually getting to play like this guy
you know getting just to do to like do
you know
like an eddie murphy or [ __ ] thing
you know what i mean just put on a fat
suit and and be just like a totally
different guy that was fun yeah
i you know what megan uh i think sent us
a list of questions
that i have here
and i could read some of them off
glenn used to be the host
well yeah no well that was you know i
think what happened was you guys sensed
uh the power dynamics shifting and you
guys were like we got to step up
otherwise howerton's going to be the
star of this thing and i can't have that
oh here she comes look at that look
this thing was going over like a red
balloon man let me tell you
here we go what happened i had your
questions i was gonna read your
questions off but now you're here and
you could do it so are you are you all
set up over there microphone and
everything recording and yeah you're i
have my microphone yes i'm in a coffin
i have actually
i have a
lot this will prove that i'm here
because we don't have this brand in the
states i don't think so
um drinking meghan is what night at like
seven o'clock or uh six six o'clock at
night there is that is that right
five i think five thirty five
okay yeah but i gotta stay risky i gotta
i gotta stay up until like ten tonight
to beat this jet lag
so
do you have your bags and everything
megan or are they just like getting
around in the
things
no you got your bag
and then you got to a little quiet area
how do you find a quiet area in the
middle of an airport i don't understand
like i hear this bustle but i like it
it's it's that yeah but you're sitting
on a nice leather couch and [ __ ] like
where where do you find something i'm in
a little coffee shop well the airports
in um the uk are lovely heathrow airport
is like my favorite sometimes i come
here early just to like hang out here
because it's nice
they [ __ ] everybody hates you at lax
you know what i mean like the second you
walk in they're like move keep moving
move
keep it moving like you have to stop
your car for like two seconds at the
curb to let your friend out it's like
let's go get the car out of here i need
all the cars out of here
don't you love too when like you're
going to say and they've changed a rule
where they're like we don't need you to
take laptops of bags anymore and then
they're like irritated with you for not
knowing it like they're like no keep
your shoes on you're like well
once you want again people you get to
keep one shoe on okay all right once you
on as long as you have an orange sock if
you have an orange sock you can keep
your boat shoes on but if you got white
socks you got to take a third of a shoe
off okay don't make me say it again
the flip side of that is the 75 percent
of people who get who who stand in a
line for an hour then they get to the
very front of it and then they have no
idea why they're there what's going on
apparently oh he's never been on an
airplane before they don't know that
they have to walk through a metal
detector and that oh their phone will
set it off or might set it off and
therefore it shouldn't be in your pocket
that's pretty frustrating yeah that's i
there was a lady who was incensed she
couldn't bring her giant bottle of water
through she was drinking it's like is
this your first time flying
yeah you never heard that you did that's
like something that even if you haven't
been to you don't look like the kind of
person that is your first time flying so
you should know this you know what here
they've done away with the customs like
you just put your passport on like a
machine and it just opens a door and you
like walk through but i kind of miss
like the interaction with the customs
official but i came here once to the uk
and they were asking me questions about
like what was my business here and i was
saying like oh i'm seeing my husband and
they were like what's your business and
i was like i work in television and then
the customs guy was like do you make a
lot of money at that and i was like dude
i have to answer that like he just was
curious and so he was just asking me how
much money i made and i was like it's
just weird he was like no i'm just
interested i was like well it's weird
and the capacity of you being a customs
agent to ask me questions like that
right you got how much you got on you
right now like what how much you got
you know let's let's just say you were
having the trouble getting through
you have the means to uh would you have
the the ability to uh you know grease
the grease the squeaky wheel as as it
were you know to grease and grease some
palms those tips are they real or what
you got working with over there it's
like that's sort of questionable
there are other ways to get into this
television effect
[Laughter]
i i i've talked to i'm sure i know i've
bitched to you guys about this before
but one of my
just all-time most infuriating and
confusing things is you know the number
of times i've been you know you're
waiting at the ticket counter you don't
have to do this kiosks now so this is
kind of an older problem but like when
you wait at the ticket counter to give
them your bags and get you know uh
issued your ticket you know you walk up
here's here here's all it is you walk up
you hand them your id which you should
already have in your [ __ ] hand unless
you're an [ __ ]
you hand them the id
they print the ticket out they get your
bag they put it on and you're gone
within within three minutes i'm out of
there you know
and yet every single [ __ ] that's
in front of me
is like the per the the person's on the
computer
like [ __ ] writing a writing a [ __ ]
novella
you're like what are you what are you
doing does this person have like who
shows it like i imagine people show up
to the airport and they're like
what is what is this place and they're
like oh this is an airport
oh okay well [ __ ] maybe i should go
somewhere yeah maybe you should and it
just goes on and on they're like
where do you guys fly to like what
how does it take that long like to get
you either have a [ __ ] ticket for
this flight or you don't what are you
doing
i never understood that it drives me
crazy you you've always been one
negotiator you've always been one to get
very fairly frustrated
at say
a a coffee shop where there's a line of
you know eight people and then you have
the people waiting in line and it takes
maybe like 12 minutes or maybe it's less
maybe it's four minutes it doesn't
matter the point is when the person
finally gets up to the the barista and
then says then starts looking at the
menu and doesn't know what it is
that they want to get okay let's see
like i'm gonna [ __ ] punch you in the
back of the neck you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like what is that i just
now meg we've spent the first half of
the podcast complaining about the french
do you see any french people around you
have you heard them are you seeing
anybody around you who is acting like an
[ __ ]
um i i haven't seen any any french
people around but i'll let you know
there must be some i'm in the
international arrivals terminal so
everybody's here it's actually the one
they shot um love actually in
um so
the you guys probably never seen love
actually but um women will know that uh
this is the terminal they shot the
arrivals seen in
love
the three of us shook our heads
yeah love actually
i mean they may as well have titled that
movie men don't bother
you know and they didn't
didn't
actually
uh love
actually sarcastic with me movie title
[ __ ] you
yeah um it's love
uh actually it's love
yeah
yeah so
all right okay so there you go
um the answer
what is that what does that mean was was
the question posed
um
are you with me for the sex
or are you with me for something else
sweetie um are you with me for my money
uh love
actually
yeah yeah let's let's let's talk let's
let's talk about a movie that we've
never seen actually and pontificate on
why the movie is called why the title i
like that game yeah okay
i think it could also be um that it's
like you thought you were in love with
somebody
but then you meet somebody else and
you're like
actually that's love i didn't realize
that until i met this person
this is love actually
the thing before was that's most likely
i thought it was that's did i get too
real did i did i did i'd not be funny
and i actually nailed it meg did i nail
it does that matter like someone who's
incapable of feeling love and then
suddenly like starts to feel it and like
this is actually
this is actual love
it's actually that
yeah what if what if the movie is about
a guy named phil actually
phil actually yeah and right and then
there's a there's star cross lovers
there's a woman named jane and
she falls she falls in love
actually jane love falls in love with
phil actually
mm-hmm and uh this is great this is
really good stuff all right so we've got
to see who's in that who's in that movie
who's in that movie everyone right isn't
it one of those
lots like 500 people in that movie yeah
because it's like six different stories
i i prefer your version of it to the
actual one so i'm not going to tell you
guys what happens in it because
you should break our own version yeah i
probably did see it and just don't
remember seeing it it sounds like a hugh
grant movie was he in that is that a
hugh grant joint yes hugh grant wasn't
it oh he
was
of course he was what are you kidding he
was
he was in love actually i believe he
played the prime minister
in the movie of love
the prime minister
ladies and gentlemen the prime minister
of love
love actually
um
oh it's a christmas movie it's a
christmas movie it's a christmas movie
the prime minister of kindness of love
actually
that's that's the first line
listen to this cast for one second
hugh grant liam neeson colin firth laura
linney emma thompson alan rickman keira
knightley martine mccutcheon don't know
bill nye rowan atkinson i must see this
movie these are fantastic actors we're
missing out yeah i mean you know it
doesn't tickle my fancy i saw the poster
i know all those people are in there i
still think they'll see they're great
they're great actors hey they're great
they just need to do them now if the
movie was called
guns actually i probably would have gone
to sleep
you know fists fists actually you know
i'd be like [ __ ] yeah man what is that
like what is that [ __ ] like yeah or fist
action lee and it's about a guy named
lee and his fist action
yeah
are we ever going to talk about this
episode let's do it there was one scene
and i don't remember which it was where
i was behind the monitors watching you
guys
it might have even just been part of the
scene and and my stand-in
was doing the thing where he was holding
his breath as me
um
i don't remember which shot it is i
think it's maybe when the lady comes in
to speak to us and then after i
i don't know why we did that
but i think in those early seasons we
had so little trust about anyone
except what i know exactly why we would
have done that yes because we're control
freaks and somebody had to be behind the
camera yeah so i was behind the camera i
always remember being like wow this guy
i think his name was david who was my
stand-in um that season was like ripped
like it was like this guy
handsome david david was really happy
handsome handsome guy and uh strong and
i was like wow great man good standing
good good double the thing where where
he sp where frank falls against the wall
and spills all the the chicken parts
did that did that line was like ah you
you made me drop all the chicken parts
or whatever is that line in the episode
or is that just in the bloopers
i just remember think thinking that was
really funny to th the the the idea that
he's not cooking chicken he's cooking
chicken parts yeah he says that in the
episode he does okay i couldn't remember
yeah yeah i always i always liked that
like you know chicken parsley
there's a couple specific things in
there that i i remember
during the writing process being really
pleased with
um the like the very spec
the specificity of turkey sangria and i
remember like writing that and thinking
it was funny and then i remember you
guys reading that and laughing and being
like what is that and i
said i i don't know but it just sounds
funny and your imagination goes to
whatever that might be
turkey sangria at the dinner party you
the whatever was on the plates was just
like a gray sort of like
mash like oh yeah yeah i remember that i
remember just shooting that and being
like why does it look like this but
everything's funny
yeah everything just looks like devoid
completely different because we made it
yeah yeah cause our characters made it
yeah yeah yeah well i really think it
really helps you
see how these people became who they
became
their parents i mean are ins the parents
are worse than the characters yeah their
parents are insane or worse than our
characters yeah oh this by the way is
the um mrs mac beau episode which is
yeah yeah you mentioned it in the last
one but
yeah oh that's right i mixed them up
that's right yeah this is the one with
the correct i remember because you
watched them both uh but like i did
yeah i couldn't help myself
um yeah you know what threw me on this
one though is is dee's motivation for
getting dennis beat up
um
i kind of felt
like something that we
didn't do before and haven't really done
since like where the characters will
definitely like screw each other over
for their own
needs and wants but probably never to
like that kind of an extent like to get
somebody hurt
intentionally i mean i guess we just did
lighter on fire an episode before but
that was the very first time
what was the motivation that ended that
episode where we put dennis into a
situation where he was assaulted oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah and the first
time the first one the very first one
that's the very first time but that's
not how that was supposed to happen
that that it went down the wrong
went down the wrong way
he was supposed to just wake up in bed
with a guy and the guy was supposed to
uh scare dennis into not wanting to be a
gay bar anymore yeah he was supposed to
be a couple guys from dee's acting class
but uh she she couldn't get those guys
so whoever those guys were just random
dudes that i picked up when i was drunk
as [ __ ] like
that's basically what we're saying so
technically i don't think it really was
you know your fault
but uh
yeah i know i i i think it i
i think it i think it's fine uh it's
it's fun to see dee um you know do
something so manipulative and uh
you know use my use my uh narcissism
against me um i'm always a fan of that
it's fine
your voice says wendell uh
your your fat suit voice i remember
throwing throwing us off the first time
because you didn't really tell us what
you were gonna do
yeah i thought it'd be more fun to just
kind of come in and do it once i was in
the fat suit in full hair and makeup and
just start doing it but uh by the way i
didn't even know what the voice was
gonna be either until i got into the
full
thing and saw it once i saw it i was
like oh okay
uh you know it's gotta just be it
really what it was was just like a
really really bad al pacino
impersonation
like that's all it really is it's just a
a a really bad album and i knew it was
bad enough to where i was like people
wouldn't know that i was doing an al
pacino
like impersonation because
i can't do one well and so i was like oh
that's good for the character then and i
remember and there's a great there's a
great blooper of it though of uh
you know
i don't know like i'm saying the lines
or something and then what you step in
charlie who steps in you somebody steps
in and starts doing it
yeah
well we all try we all gave it a shot
because you
we did a very
high-end special effect for us at the
time where we were doing a split screen
because you were obviously playing both
characters so we needed somebody to come
in and read the other side of those
lines no we didn't do a split screen
version of it
we didn't do it whatever it was we did
we did an over the we we did some kind
of it was it was a practice yeah the
trick is you just put someone in like
glenn's jacket who looks like him and
shoot over his shoulder towards glenn in
the fat suit then you turn back around
and you shoot over a stand-in who looks
like glenn in the fat suit back to glenn
yeah i mean it's pretty like basic
oh so you they did it in the 20s or the
30s i mean it's that well so i came in
and for whatever reason i instead of
reading the lines just
i tried to do the voice that you did
oh yeah that's right that's a blooper oh
yeah
yeah
it's like just having a swollen tongue
yeah yeah that's right
yeah well it's like it's like could you
pick a picture they're just being you
know things pressing up against the
vocal cords um you know maybe if you've
if you've gained a little too much
weight maybe there's something kind of
you know constricting things you know
uh
so that was the that was the thought
there but um
[Music]
uh yeah i think and i think the idea of
eating a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich when i answered the door was
the last minute edition i don't think
that was in the scriptures thought like
it'd be funny if he's like eating a you
know sloppy peanut butter and jelly
sandwich when he answers the door
it's a nice little addition i think it's
got adds a nice little touch to it
uh
but yeah that was that was super fun
that little kid is
that kid is very funny timmy
yeah very disturbing that's
that's very disturbing i mean it's all
it's all just innuendo and fun until the
very until the final line
and i i'm sure we sat there
and didn't really labor over whether or
not we should do it it was just whatever
whatever that final exclamation point at
the end of it was was probably bandied
about
and then glenn you you say you know like
okay i get it i'll i'll take off and you
throw the kid a little wink
which
yes
yeah it's just awful you say you say
he's there he's not reformed in any way
you're out there taking the heat well
i'm in here watching the disney channel
yeah that's what you're doing
yeah yeah yeah yeah why the hell would i
move
[Laughter]
so so horrible do you guys um are there
what are there celebrities uh or or or
people that you've seen that are just
absolutely like uncanny doppelgangers
for you
well i can tell you the ones i get all
the time
yeah
well helly jones it used to be a thing
although it's less so yep these days
yeah
haley and i look a lot of like um rob
you got that one on the plane that one
time
what was the one on the plane
oh um the guy from oh yeah uh a woman
comes up to me and she says oh i'm such
a big fan of yours and i said oh thank
you so much and she said oh do you think
we could get a photo i say sure we take
a photo and she goes i love burn notice
and i was like oh i've never seen oh
i've never seen that show
and then i'm thinking you do look like
that she's watching it yeah so she's
like a bird noticed like my favorite
shows are coming back and i was like i
don't know
i haven't seen it yeah isn't his name
jeffrey down all day oh he's a very good
looking guy and he's he's also a
fantastic actor he's great
yeah he's great in fargo
glenn do you get people do you get
people
i don't know um okay
not
really somebody uh oh yeah you know who
i get these days is uh people
compare me to jonathan groff
um
i see that a little bit
a little yeah
yeah i get pete wentz quite a bit and i
know that pete wentz gets me he's told
me that a lot of people will will say
the same thing and yeah there was also a
band that i've i'd never heard uh any of
their music but i got
um i think you guys were always sort of
around when the show first premiered and
we would go to events and there would be
people taking photographs of us and no
one had ever seen or heard of our show
but people thought that i was the lead
singer of the band hubba stank and you
guys were all in the band what a name
yeah so i would get a lot of
hoobastank comments yeah who was tank
guy i by the way there's you know for
those for those and i'm sure there's
like mo vast majority of people that are
listening or watching this uh have never
actually experienced being on a red
carpet okay there let me tell you
something
there is nothing more humiliating
than stepping onto a world a a red
carpet for some sort of an event
sometimes it's sometimes it would be the
event that was like celebrating the
thing that i'm in
and walking the red carpet having all
these people take photos of you and
after they take the photo they yell at
you
who are you what's your name
you tell them
and you're like oh my god that is so
embarrassing they're like how do you
spell it
they want to know how to spell you're
like
that doesn't still happen to you right
no no no but that was that was something
that would happen a lot like in the
beginning early seasons yeah yeah for
sure people were like
oh okay he's on the red carpet i know i
have to take photos of him and then
afterwards like can you tell us your
name who the hell are you how am i gonna
sell these pictures
uh charles i get like uh people like
regular people like people like hey this
is my buddy i just met in a bar and he's
short and has a beard and scruffy hair
and he never looks like you i i get a
lot i've seen a lot of that on social
media where people are like look at my
my buddies like looks exactly like
charlie and i'm like no he doesn't no i
don't see a lot of it uh the basketball
player wants some that i saw
that was pretty funny there's a guy on
the
mavericks i think
and he's got to be like seven feet tall
so uh but there was like someone had
cobbled together like a series of
pictures of him and then me and i was
like okay that was pretty funny yes yeah
yeah yeah i've never seen that that was
that was a pretty good one yeah meg what
about you is any anyone is there anyone
who people are like oh you look like
so-and-so
i get um
selma blair
um yeah
but maybe not after an eleven hour
flight um
and uh actually the most accurate one
i've ever gotten is that there's this
movie called um welcome to the dollhouse
which is like a dark comedy about this
young girl who's like everybody hates
basically
and she looks really nerdy and she looks
exactly like i looked when i was younger
like we'll put i'll put side-by-side
pictures up in the podcast i mean 280
that is what i looked like when i was a
kid
[Laughter]
that movie is amazing it's amazing
that's todd's salons right
yes yeah i got one that i was very
excited about recently uh maybe six
months ago i was very excited i was in
pretty good shape
and i had i to be fair i had a hat on
and i had it down really low
and i was sitting out at a at lunch and
some guy comes up and he's like oh
[ __ ] man can i take a photo with you
and i'm like sure sure and we we take a
photo and he's like oh man i just i i
love a lot of your [ __ ] but like my
favorite stuff is like back in the day
i'm like okay cool he goes i the the
departed man the i love the departed and
i was like
okay
wow what's going on
right you're right
he thought i was wahlberg
and i was like oh man i'm not
i'm not mark wahlberg and he's like oh
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] you and then he ran
away
yeah yeah you [ __ ] are you
yeah you [ __ ] are you can i and i
told that i told that story to to mark
wahlberg and he looked like actually
what
yeah right
yeah yeah yeah
you wish buddy
you wish pal you [ __ ] wish yeah
that's not even possible we'll be
leaving the same size
you don't even look like
he's always just he's slightly worked
out yeah he's always just worked out
you know we uh we both got on a flapping
hat that's it what do they even say
that's my do that yeah do you think that
he like drops down and does like [ __ ]
25 push-ups before every take of
something you know what i mean so he is
so he's like legitimately out of breath
adds like intensity to the scene but
also like he gets a pump you know what i
mean
whatever he's doing it's working because
i'll watch that guy in anything yes
absolutely
yeah absolutely um
well rob uh
you've got a sibling
uh who is now a writer on it's always
sunny in philadelphia um and a very good
one i have to say it was it's been very
uh refreshing and uh fun having her in
the writers room because she's really
brilliant uh but she's in this episode
and she's your sister she is yes she is
yeah she's also a a writer great writer
on mr quest as well the other one though
ah yes mr quest uh mr quest mr famous
appleship
um katie mack is uh she calls you an
[ __ ] or uh creep or something like
that yeah yeah she says she's the one
who uh says uh pervert [ __ ] i think
right
yeah yeah yeah wait in addition to katie
you have another sibling pat
does pat
do people stop pat and and think that
it's you
because yes you and pat look a lot of
like except that pat keeps his hair kind
of blonde mostly but yes my brother my
brother we have we have we have
different coloring blonde hair he's
blond hair blue eyes and i'm brown hair
brown eyes and yet we do look so much
alike
that he gets mistaken for me all the
time
yeah and he uses it
because he he'll use it to like say if
someone's like oh do you want to come to
the front of the line of somewhere
somewhere where we all almost always
will say no because we don't want to be
[ __ ] that cut in front of lines
he'll just go yeah because
us i've seen yes to that every time are
you [ __ ] kidding me somebody asked me
if i want to go to the front of the line
because i'm who i am i like yes
yeah
absolutely well it's not going to work
anymore at french restaurants
they're not going to let pat in
yeah it'll work they they don't watch
this that well it won't work because
they don't watch the show and they
certainly don't listen to this podcast
french [ __ ] no they don't
[Music]
uh gregory scott cummins is back for
this playing mac's dad
one of my favorite all-time favorite
guest stars he's such a marvelous
marvelously funny guy
uh and i just love him so much but he
refers to um
uh the the uh sexual offender um as uh
as wendell's short eyes now
uh rob would you like to explain to
everyone what what the term short eyes
means for those of you who haven't spent
much time in prison yes uh we learned
sometime around that year that short
eyes was the term that uh inmates would
refer to
pedophiles
as or pedophiles here in the united
states
they would refer to them as short eyes
and then of course they became victims
because there is some kind of um honor
amongst
amongst thieves in prison where uh if
you are a convicted child uh abuser they
will take care of you
uh prison style
that's right where did they get the
short eyes from though
you got eyes for the short people i
don't know
uh yeah i don't know i'm not exactly
sure what the origins
[Laughter]
oh well done
well done
god damn you here
that's pretty that's uh oh boy
well i could go on and on about uh
gregory scott cummins because i love him
but we could also we should also you
know give props to uh
to uh mac's mom and uh charlie's mom um
lynne marie is so funny in this episode
the way she
the way she plays it when danny comes in
and like every time he shuts her up and
she just immediately just stops talking
she's just
oh gosh she's so funny
hey guys uh short eyes is old-school
prison slang for a child molester that
entered the public lexicon in the late
1970s when miguel pinero adapted his
play short eyes into a movie with the
same title the movie's about a pedophile
who gets tortured and ultimately killed
by his fellow inmates after they find
out what he's in jail for so it's based
so it's based on a term that was used in
the play
bar based on the name of the play the
yes the the the name of the play a lot
of big theater fans in prison a lot of
big theater fans in prison a lot in
other regions i see that play you see
that have you ever read have you ever
actually read moliere
yeah but have you read it
no but like yeah read it read it bro
tattoo
[Laughter]
great playwrights
tartuffe have you read tartuffe it's
unfucking
it's not unbelievable
you want to laugh you want to laugh you
want to laugh yeah you want some moliere
read some moliere all right trust me
yeah yeah
what's uh what's another one
[Laughter]
okay guys um this has been a lot of fun
i truly truly enjoyed this
um
megan have you seen glenn's head have
you seen glenn's head for all the creeps
out there because we could we could do a
reveal for megan ooh i haven't seen it
okay well it it's it's
yeah so the character i'm playing in
this movie is bald on top um
but it you'll see you'll see the fuzz
because i haven't we did we've only done
a hair and makeup test and that was on
friday so what i have to go through that
because it doesn't you know people are
like oh no you're here
i can see hair
that's so good
yeah amazing
it's kind of steve jobby alarming
yeah i mean i'll obviously i'll shave it
down to the skin i think i think the
plan is to shave it down to the skin
like up to like here and have like a
little bit you know just have it kind of
a little a little fuzz like maybe on top
like right here
um
as is often the case um to try and make
it look as real as possible but yeah
yeah the character i'm playing is
actually quite tan
okay it's it's it's better from the side
you know what i mean he's a real actor
that's real actor stuff that what that's
some real actory [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's true
um
that's it we've done it i did it